how's it goin breasts man is pure and
welcome to obscurity I bet you won't
expect the net value I know a lot of you
brothers a little sad that I don't play
as much as an e shape as I used to and
the reason for that it's just because I
already played so much [ __ ] amnesia
but this cousin sorry looked really good
and they promised chilling atmosphere
that's good
frightening horror no I like that
complex and deep storyline
I like that to richly detailed
environments and Lighting's love it
quality cut voice acting love it cuts
the monsters I'm there out there let's
go and that's always in amnesia when it
loads that means you and I get to
connect I love that this is like our
special time that we shared together
instead of just me talking to myself all
the time because that's done what I'm
doing right now I'm talking to you
whatever your name is what's that okay
fine well I'm gonna play now if you
don't mind Jace always blabbing about
what sorry sorry I mean to offend you
that's is there that always starts with
me waking up in the middle of the woods
it does always start with that every
constant story ever except you wake up
in like a the house or whatever and it
always continues we're looking for the
lantern but it always feels strangely
real ah
I'm disoriented and confused ah
interesting
I like the voice acting so far alright
quite nice sounds like a better
microphone that I have or at least very
stumble through the foliage you lose a
familiarity back to me so we have been
here before in the four Dainius pit
strikes already bet you weren't
expecting that all right Cole there's
house over there however something is
wrong
I'm not that is creepy man that is
creepy bad bro don't you dare
something is stalking me oh okay so far
so good this is actually really [ __ ]
creepy let's hurry up to the house
I'm Radek I click through systems shift
to monetize my house but usually I'm not
able to reach the front door however I
sure [ __ ] hope so
ah man
Oh Janna fire you look wonderful today
okay almost there now I don't even want
to know what happens if we don't reach
the front door just want to go here
oh thank heavens I grabbed the doorknob
twisted [ __ ] Plan B everyone glad babe
screamed like a little girl come to
Crescent village that's so ironic oh man
what a [ __ ] intro [ __ ] piece of
dicks my mouse is disco wait let me
pause there we go
I click shift too many times and it was
just [ __ ] me over that's hilarious
electric red presence what are you
present to us obscurity very very
interesting so far very interesting
[Music]
I'm terribly sorry about all these I
hope I can fixes while editing there we
go
[Music]
Chrisann village disappearances
continues that I correct their grammar
there isn't string of disappearances in
the small mining community of Crescent
village have continued this week with at
least four missing persons reported
local suggested that the mines are to
blame and that the dangerous come on
oh well I believe you can pause or
whatever and it kind of sucks I wanted
to know just yesterday afternoon a body
turned up in the forest surrounded
Crescent village police have yet to
identify the victim but it seems to be a
child the body was found mangled and
almost unrecognizable and there is no
clear cause of death analysts suggest
that it must have been the work of a
large animal but the locals are not
convinced it reminds me a lot of Silent
Hill so far the whole come to Crescent
village or whatever but that's okay I
mean everyone [ __ ] rips off Santa's
this is victim the following
continuation of this very aggressive
village including the police officer
police have officially cease the
investigation until further notice due
to lack of leads of evidence they came
to conclusion that conditioning Kristen
bills are not simply not are simply not
inhabitable the suspect the minds are at
fault and that they are simply too
dangerous to be in operation officially
I shut down demise and urge Kristen
village inhabitants to somewhere else
I'm fortunate most of that no worker
main place up in [ __ ] sorry by that any
nothing Pierce can do about it what am I
only know I'm in a horse ride haunting
me in my dreams
it was a small but peaceful all right
there for my parents my sister
I don't remember much one day my sister
died and I was sent away to London but
there with my arms uncle since then I've
never had any contact with my family
they wrote letters at first but they
never responded bastards
numerous attempts to hear from my
parents again I gave up
I thought they had forgotten about me
all right eventually the memories of my
childhood slipped away I became a
successful lawyer working at a small law
firm I never looked back
why should he leave but now my past is
haunting me no no it's nightmares I'm
having or remnants of my childhood
oh that's why I'm champion in Crescent
village something happened there that I
don't remember don't get affected all
right no this sort hasn't been done
before but it's still interesting feels
wrong about all my instincts are telling
me to stay away from that but yet you
are going there no I must rid myself of
these awful nightmares okay you do that
lady well that now I'll be there I'll be
there man love the horse ride thing I
wish I wish to me and there Ken was
actually talking about something
yesterday I thought it's kind of funny
that there are literally no naked women
in amnesia it's only naked naked men
only
it's kind of weird isn't it I I hope I
hope Anisha the machine work for pigs
will have some titties in it
Crescent village ahead
well here we are it's kind of creepy
already honestly but I like that you
have the lantern I'm so [ __ ] sick of
finding that thing it's like oh I find
the lantern hey I don't know why they
make us keep finding in i felt quite
contempt having it right here who's a
blonde okay we're going wait going no
light that was probably someone being
really hungry and the bad part is they
probably won't eat me [ __ ] now my pets
got my lantern everything is quiet in
order quite an order where is this
village anyway
geez what a [ __ ] entrance ha I don't
even know
so it's loving again so tell me about
the fig you were telling me about it
before you aren't saying anything well
tell me ad out sorry sorry Jays
wolfblood [ __ ] happened here Wow seemed
so empty I had to go find some help I'm
pretty much stranded here
let's follow in the period as usual [ __ ]
requires a key key my ass literally do
it do it please someone well oh hello
later have you take a bath it's been a
long journey I would need it hmm we
repair all the [ __ ] doors are locked
what about this one oh [ __ ] don't tell
me we're going to the mines right away I
don't need to go through gravy right now
what is this do not add day hahaha you
can't stop me
bad pills I picked that latter piece
three out of three interesting what is
this a cheese the elevator obtain all
three fuel rods place them in the proper
positions when all units are placed
falafel lever only authorized personnel
okay let's find those I said Nikhil
before in case you were worried it's
just a word I'm not a racist
I love bald people I love dinosaurs I
love cats I love Asian cats I love paper
I actually don't like cats that much Wow
I guess I'm supposed to go up there oh I
get it alright
I thought I had three out of three
pieces now you know make no sense so we
got to find the last piece and climb up
there huh interesting this door will not
work yep alright a few days ago one of
my local children went missing her body
was never found
was found twisted and ripped open with
revin this morning everyone else
thinking this must have been some kind
of
I'll tell it but I know what really
happened I did it oh there you are
quartz led that we're on a roll today a
leverage hello hello chess lovely
weather lovely sky everything is just
beautiful all right let's put you there
dad can I combine these no why would I
need just a bunch of parts of a ladder
it looks so perfect they're like what am
I supposed to click hmm that don't make
no sense
we got the ladder that should be the
difficult part maybe to go down
somewhere what I was supposed to yeah
why didn't the hell what am I doing
wrong Bruce what what am I doing wrong
hmm what I heard something but how did
you get up there Ruby who named you rube
it anyway
yes no way I tried this flapper it took
me forever to do that I mean yep it took
me like two seconds because but I'm a
genius man I didn't cheat either I don't
need a cheat sheet Egan's for loser
do I look like a you a little sir to you
huh I'll find that if you want to be
rude why don't you just it's just kid I
can't be angry at here you're just too
beautiful god damn it I know it's not
that I moved my heartbeat sensor while I
was getting scared so pot whoa I'm sorry
to throw you out the window that would
have been crazy I can't leave yet I need
to find what's going on what do you
think about that Jesus I don't know
touch my nipples maybe
why do you always want that money always
wanted me to touch that's really gay
nothing wrong with the game being gay
paddy okay well I actually agree with
you
I'm real glad you think's up here
tonight squeeze them just a little
squeeze one own and the one will it pity
sorry Jesus maybe later I'm busy now
I'll be waiting for your pay they good I
guess we just gotta look around and then
a candle I don't have any [ __ ]
tinderboxes how about that how about you
our love was just the wind just the wind
what happened here what happened here
what did you do huh whoa Joe what is
going on at carpet it was here all along
wasn't it yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] paintings
man alright
it's funny how [ __ ] carpets get job
lovin what fun okay dear Anne hopefully
I will come but I will be back home
before you receive this letter however I
felt inclined to write to you as we
never shared proper goodbyes I should
inform you that Crescent village is
actually quite nice it's quite little
place and people seem to keep themself
here Benny I'm saying is this Pleasant
and the man who runs it is plainly fled
to be honest though I don't like it here
letters have been sense of dread the
lingering in the air I feel like
something terrible is gonna happen I've
been trying to ignore it but it's been
keeping me up on at night this could
just be paranor no yeah but Kristen
village has been giving me a sinister
uncomfortable vibe ever since I arrived
even when I'm alone I feel as if I'm
being watched again maybe it's just me
after all it's not used to trap I'm not
used to traveling either way I am
looking forward to leaving this village
and seeing it again sincerely dear
sister Margot I'm
really terrible and reading I wish I was
better honestly but hey I know how never
ever ever in a in a horror vide video
movie game whatever horror story
have a character been wrong about being
paranoid hey kids it's time I waited a
long time I'm sick of waiting to squeeze
them on writing sorry Jesus you will
have to wait
god dammit well your nipple squeezing
will be worth it I shall wait forever if
I have to show up at the white Jesus oh
thank you I think this should go to one
of the houses welcome I apologize for
not being able to be here on your first
day but at the moment we have only one
customers staying in the end her name is
Margaret and she should be fine for a
while all you need to do is serve her
and local any logos I might stop by my
office is next door to this room and
it's usually open so if for some reason
you need something from there you're
free to enter a seat please
one last thing if you run out of beer
there's a keg in the cellar
how are the sella must remain locked at
all times whenever you're down there I
advise you leave quickly and make sure
you lock the door behind you I don't say
this lightly the key is including this
mansion best of luck Arthur [ __ ] who
would have thought it would be so
difficult to just get some beer looks
like we're going to the cellar Jesus
loved the cellar whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
I'm scared heads scratched my nipples
quickly [ __ ] that
whoa
they really barricaded that door for a
reason that is [ __ ] creating that
giving me the heat creepers I don't like
that the question is should be unblocked
the door to go out or should we go to
the cellar I think we should look for
this cellar honestly whoa
la da Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada
perfect don't think pets I really don't
want to go with you I really don't well
you ain't got no choice [ __ ] yeah yeah
alright not to bounce not a good sign
but hey it looks like we'll have to go
anyway alright now - easy pets you do
not want to [ __ ] with these people down
here where's the beer
where is ya hi I told you it open I told
you it all [ __ ] the horse man Jesus
whatwhat was it pin it not you hey where
did you go Jay says no no wow [ __ ] don't
worry live heads come back to me okay
okay I well hey a crowbar we could use
that
oh well you said on the outside thing or
whatever the [ __ ] genius kids performs
again now we weren't here for the beer
didn't we I guess we didn't really do it
for the beer oh wow
let's go unless there's something I
missed
nope alright helm it is lock-in the door
the question is should I remove these or
not I don't know I don't think they're
oh I can okay call this tit bah bah bah
there we go it won't open
[ __ ] all right a little go through the
window then Jake says what is it Pat it
oh [ __ ] I forgot about it
I bet it's waiting there for me all
luscious and beautiful pears
oh yeah all right you're coming with me
and I need to find out what's going on
what I got the crowbar I can't go well
[ __ ] I guess I missed something
what did i miss no what did podes miss
well we're then going here did we uh
what about the crowbar oh that way
yes that's right [ __ ] hopefully
now we'll find out what's going on I'm
father day they finally come for me they
barricaded the front door and locked
myself in the office I can hear them
outside trying to find a way in there is
no escape this is the end I write this
as a hope in hopes that someday someone
will find this and know the true story
of Christine village I don't know how
much that's my job always been simple I
was to bring outsider into the village
in staying at my end the community would
then come to them type to take them away
and they were never seen a guy has been
having for years now and I never
questioned it if I refused they would
have killed me along with the rest
however their most recent abduction was
very messy and I witnessed it they would
the way they killed Margaret it was
awful
I can't take this anymore I officially
closed the end and now the communion is
coming for me too I'm going to hide in
the closet I don't know what's gonna
happen to me but it's not the door
behind me
[Music]
oh my [ __ ]
they [ __ ] said Noah jump-scares those
little [ __ ] oh my [ __ ] god
oh I both my legs just BAM right in
better oh [ __ ] me man I'm out of here
I'm out of here
that was fun [ __ ] that [ __ ] by myself
oh [ __ ] alleged I know you caught it
that nice party had a bad day